i'm under sheriff christopher darcy
and i really wanted to address our
community this afternoon
about the verdict in the derek shawvan
trial today
the death of mr floyd has become a
seminal event in law enforcement
and within our community the chauvin
trial brought up a bigger issue about
american policing
and we're always willing to have that
conversation here at the lvmpd
we've been having this conversation for
nearly a decade
when we began reforms here on our agency
substantive changes are not just
procedural they're cultural
we have worked hard to ensure that there
is no environment
on this police department for an officer
like derek shaubin
many changes have happened over time
with the guidance and input
of community members and representatives
from our metro multicultural
advisory council these members have
really helped us learn
and implement change and have championed
some of our most important policy
changes
in addition we willingly work with these
faith-based partners
community groups and even some of our
critics
i want to say that i am so happy that we
have some of our community partners
here with us today standing over here
to my right mujahideen ramadan
has been working with metro since i was
a very young officer
brought up on this agency and you can
tell that's a long time ago with the
gray hair
but i remember sitting there as like a
brand new cop
and he was teaching us about diversity
and biases and how we can overcome those
by working together
next to mr ramadan we have other members
of our community that
that came to us today and said we would
like to be part of this
we would like to be part of what's going
on with your organization
so i want to thank reverend jackson
pastor gaston reverend wright
and pastor cherry and maria barnes for
taking time out of their day
to come here and be with us so thank you
very much
with our partners we've been able to
start working on recruiting a more
diverse police
officer so our agency will better
reflect the community
that we serve we've been making changes
prior to mr floyd's death metro made
several changes in our use of poly
force policy and training policies
to name a few mandating a recovery
position
making that mandatory so that when we
have a suspect in custody we ensure that
they are breathing and their breathing
is not restricted when they're in
custody
mandating a duty to intervene and a duty
to report
when an officer sees another officer or
a supervisor sees an officer
doing something improper providing more
direction
in what de-escalation really means and
training our folks
on how to de-escalate making that part
of the fabric of everything we do
every call we go on we talk about
de-escalation
we've prohibited choke holds and neck
restraints
we've made changes and we've learned
over time that we have a responsibility
to listen to our community
to you to learn from our community and
to change
the strength of our police department
comes from this community
it comes from you the public among our
many duties to the public
we're here to protect the first
amendment right
to assemble protest some of you may
choose to exercise that right today
and we stand here with you the community
to ensure hand in hand
that they remain peaceful and the
message is heard
this last year has really illustrated a
number
of issues that really impact our
community
and the death of mr floyd was a tragic
event
that should not have happened
having said that today a jury has spoken
and held a police officer accountable
for their conduct
our hope at the lvnpd as we continue to
work collaboratively
and we continue to earn the public's
trust
so i want to thank you all for being
here i want to thank the members of the
community i want to thank my officers
that are here
as well as members of the media and the
public
i am willing to take some questions if
you have any questions of me today
a couple questions talk you notice from
channel 13. i'm
curious going forward will you guys be
using this case the derek show the case
in your training now moving forward well
i will tell you this that's not within
our training
and i think there's not a person on this
planet
that looks at that and thinks that
that's okay so that's never been part of
our training nor will it be part of our
training but yes
obviously the illustration of what
not following policy results
in i think sends a powerful message
yes sir police officer nasa civilian
community member what was your feeling
when you saw that video and what was you
feeling today
when the jury came back guilty
well i will tell you um the day that i
first saw that video i had
another employee who's now a deputy
chief come into my office and said
you have to see this video it's the most
disturbing thing i've ever seen
and he says i think a city is going to
burn and
i looked at it i thought i was just
shocked so it was just utter shock and
disappointment
and then today i would say that the uh
feeling is relief
the yes real victory when it comes to
seeing an officer
held accountable in this country for the
death of an african-american
um also during this trial we've heard a
lot of talk about the blue wall of
silence
what is metro police's reaction to the
conversation that's happened about the
blue wall of silence
and what is being done to make sure that
officers
one thing to you know mandate is to make
sure that officers are actually
reporting
when something happens correct so a
couple things to that
number one we don't tolerate it we
mandate that it does not occur
and we put it in policy but like i said
you have to change a culture so the only
way to change that culture is to enforce
the policy and hold those accountable
that don't follow it
right we train our folks we tell them
what the standard is
we provide them direction on what to do
and how to really attain that standard
and now we have a policy that really
nails it down
and then we follow through and hold them
accountable and we have tracking
mechanisms obviously when we see people
that have complaints we'll hold them
accountable
so i'll take one more question with the
channel eight uh
talk about these relationships with the
community uh community leaders faith
leaders
you know from this point moving forward
how will you continue to have
conversations with them but maybe build
on that further
now that this you know ground swell has
happened over the past year what's
you know what's the big change the big
movement so i think the important thing
is to continue to have the conversation
this provides us a genesis to continue
having conversations about policing in
america and policing in our community
and i think this draws more attention to
the importance of our community
relationships
whether it's our mac council or the i
mean we're involved in thousands of
community partnerships right
every day we have that opportunity to
make a connection with a member of the
public
and i think this serves as a reminder
that we're there to serve the public
and that we work cooperatively with them
and that we continue to make those
changes in law enforcement
the public expects so thank you very
much and then we'll be available for
some questions afterwards i know the
folks from the community will be here as
well so thank you for your time today
i got the mask on right